right here here on a great night I love
you so much love all right let's let
make a competition out of it
but what a night what a week welcome to
another edition of who pulled their dick
out this week so ironic Trump is in
China because here in America this is
clearly the year of the dog let's start
just in the political room judge Roy
Moore you following this he's the
Republican up for beginning probably
going to be the senator from Alabama
okay
turns out when he was in his 30s and a
district attorney he got with a
fourteen-year-old this is the allegation
but there's a lot of people backing it
up had an inappropriate relations with
three other teenage girls I mean hit
appropriate for our state anyway so
so top Republicans are now speaking out
against the women no really Sean Hannity
had to apologize for saying it was
consensual and then and then had to
explain to the other guys at Fox News
what consensual means Alabama Republican
state representative ed Henry said that
he wants to prosecute the women he said
you can't be a victim 40 years later Roy
Moore himself says this is all just fake
news liberal media [ __ ] of course he
said that wearing a raincoat standing in
front of forever 21 may influence
he's fundraising off of this people are
sending him money it's like hearing
about disaster relief on TV and sending
money to the hurricane
but nothing beats the defense put up by
Alabama state auditor Jim Ziegler you've
heard this is the guy who said quote he
said take Joseph and Mary Mary was a
teenager
Joseph was an adult carpenter and they
became parents of Jesus that's what he
said I mean using Jesus to justify child
molestation even the Catholics went
tried it doesn't work
[Applause]
also it's been a while since I've been
in catechism but to my recollection
slight difference Joseph and Mary didn't
[ __ ] isn't that the whole point of that
story
I recall was that they now this Jim
Ziegler he's quite he said he that he
also said it's just a little bit unusual
he said there's nothing immoral or
illegal here it's not like they're
lesbians and they got it I [ __ ] that
joke up it's not like he begged lesbians
a wedding cake
you know I have to say I got a defend my
tribe here a little bit
liberals versus conservatives because
certainly sexual harassment is
absolutely the one thing we see now is
totally truly bipartisan maybe the last
thing that is but no liberal defended
Harvey Weinstein or Kevin Spacey who
might be going to jail Anthony Weiner is
in jail louis c.k we here this week did
horrific things
compare that to Trump and Roy Moore we
arrest our alleged rapists they elect
them
I mean there's a pig in the White House
he he was in Japan this week and they
took him to a sushi place and asked if
we would like some yellowtail and he
said sure what's her name I mean he's a
hey he's up big oh yeah have you been
following his trip that he went to it he
went to China I don't know if the
Chinese manipulate their currency but
they died a manipulated Ahnold trump I
mean they told him that Obama just got a
state visit but he got a state visit
plus I'm not kidding you know with the
continental breakfast the state visit
Plus nobody knows what that even means
but it completely fooled Trump and he
was just putty in their hands he's got
the best negotiator in America he's the
easiest mark on the used-car lot he left
China with nothing when he was right he
goes on about how the Chinese at raping
us and cheating us and then the trade
deficit was a scandal we couldn't live
with listen you [ __ ] he said
that to them once in his speech listen
you [ __ ]
after a little ass kissing it was was up
by the [ __ ]
but hey let's not bury the lede I feel
better
this week than I have in a full year
Democrats finally won some elections
yeah the resistance showed up at the
polls new jersey governor ship virginia
governorships what what happened was
Republicans tried a new strategy called
trumpism without Trump and it backfired
horribly apparently trumpism doesn't do
well without Trump with the Republican
base when you say [ __ ] Mexicans you have
to mean it don't phone in your racism
that was their message and this wasn't
just in Virginia that they won they won
in New Jersey
Seattle elected the first lesbian mayor
a Latino latina single mom is the mayor
in Topeka Kansas refugee from Liberia is
the mayor in Helena Montana the Virginia
State Legislature good for why you
didn't say budget Center and this is all
being trucked up to a radical new
Democratic strategy called actually
voting
[Applause]
some of the races played out like
liberal revenge fantasy I mean a shill
for the NRA was beaten by the boyfriend
of a shooting victim a Republican who
the Republican in Virginia who wrote the
anti trans bathroom bill was beaten by a
trans woman he tried to tell her where
to go to the bathroom and she said
actually I think I'll be using your
office yes yes just like with her gender
reassignment surgery she made sure
America has one less dick okay